mila's applied machine learning research  team is composed of more than 15  researchers of high caliber specialized  either in deep learning or in other  domains like physics  the purpose of the amner team is to  understand the problem of the company  and also the value of the data and to  find the right algorithms from the  academic research and to combine them to  create value for the company so here  imagine a project that can be 12 to 18  months long where miele researchers and  technical teams within a company work  together on a very very specific project  with an amazing concentration of top  researchers in ai we can help these  companies and we do we can guide them to  accelerate the development of ai in the  company improve their decision making  process and offer services to a wider  set of customers and users